hey there townscapers so
really quick i just wanted to show you
guys this video i saw earlier that oscar
stalberg
tweeted that he added garden pass i
didn't even know that i got the update i
had to go back and look at it
i was really excited and i was trying to
figure out how to do it and i went on
youtube and i tried to find some videos
and i just couldn't
so i thought i would make this for those
who were in the same situation
it's pretty easy to do you just need to
make sure that your cobblestone base
has a perimeter around your building it
needs to be two stories if it's not two
stories it won't work
so you want to go ahead and make your
building and add two stories if you open
it up at the bottom it'll turn into
cobblestone but when you make two
stories and then open it up
it keeps the grass inside so you still
have your garden then you go to the
other side and that's not going to work
so i'm going to close that up
now go to the other side and you want to
make your two stories
and then you want to open it up and
there you have one garden path
if you want the pathways to cross all
you have to do is just go in the
opposite direction
i'm going to make this little house
right here at the second story
and right click and there you go there's
one part of it
so you go over to make the other part
and you open it up
and it actually gives you a fountain so
you have a four-way path with the
fountain in the middle
it's really cute and it makes for some
really nice builds that's it for today
i'll be back tomorrow i just want to
thank you guys so much for viewing
please make sure you like and subscribe
it helps this channel out a lot
make sure you follow me on twitter and
instagram the links are at the bottom
below
and i'll see you soon